games going under the total you get the  three days ahead two days ahead so  there's always a keeping an eye on the  weather and  uh you know if it looks like there's  going to be some bad weather that total  may drop down and then if it there  the weather hits and depending on how  bad it is uh that total could drop  two or three points you know depending  on how bad the weather is  so two teams the packers and the chiefs  have this weekend off  they get a bye they've earned it they're  the favorites to go to the super bowl so  they get to rest up this week  and prepare for the next round of the  playoffs in the newsroom  i'm ron futuro reporting 8 sports now